another victim another one if they keep
checking we'll keep crushing know what
this is
hello and welcome to some gameplay
shenanigans here on PlayStation grenade
today it's all about hitman 2 and the
Miami Raceway mission let's cause havoc
and attempt to take down our targets
Robert Knox and his driver daughter
Sierra in unique and simply ridiculous
ways let the montage begin electric
generator next to a tap this can only
mean one thing someone's getting
electrocuted where's our first victim
darling do it do it do it you're gonna
fry mofo what a guy you are
thank you very much that would be my
very first victim on this stage I shall
be you for the rest of the game where
shall we put you oh my god oh my god oh
my god you know what this is it's a
shredder I have missed you Hitman season
2 right but in your I put it in your
right yeah dog how does it make you feel
Jesus Christ with the blasphemy dude
feel good you're still alive this this
is not part of the plan you should be
dead by now I'm not the best scientist I
thought I was
ah what color is that we've been eating
it's like it's got fungus in it
Ernie's black this is disgusting why am
i watching let me help you with that sir
I insist is that good for you it was for
me this is what I wanted to really do
put the correct supplement in there Wow
both targets down well done 47 thank you
Dad for an exit and we'll speak again
soon
okey-dokey it was nice meeting you
anyway sir I think you need to go back
to work just because you're dead it
doesn't mean you don't work that's not
how this country was built get to work
involved you ready for the bee to drop
the baby's gonna drop 1 2
[Music]
[Music]
should I tell you something look I have
already spiked that drink good luck
darling
what me why I didn't know I could die
there it's got to be you there's only
one left
what will happen to you I can't hear you
we're in a club we're in a club I'm
gonna clue in your saying darling
backfiring she's hot stuff yeah nobody's
bothered no one's bothered there's a
dead woman here on the floor everyone no
good day to use tuba damn weird as hell
why is nobody bothered this is freaking
me out
Oh Ellis dance
[Music]
yeah thought so get Eddie Hagan fish can
I hate him in the water with it I hate
man I've missed you yes you can be free
now my victims swim like the salmon you
are I believe see if you can outdo him
go on Tom I'm gonna flush gents hey you
where's your boss tell me where your
boss is always that doesn't matter I'm
sorry to give you don't run away
come on be a pink flamingo with a
shotgun you have no support stop running
or I'll shoot you in your damn legs
lovely working with you sir targets
don't so funny
knock heard this I'm just adjust it
increase it
then we should get some pyrotechnics
here we go here we go here she is
hello picture feature he looks like he's
looking at it
[Applause]
come on darling here we go pyro you're
gonna burn you're gonna burn Sierra oh
sorry mr. mascot but this time oh I see
the problem we have to do all three
valves not just the middle one come on
[Music]
here we go whoo laughs dos tres
from the stage this time here we go yeah
stays in the corner hitman who will
survive we shall see so the mascot died
and so did the president preventing I my
business no let's attempt to throw him
onto the track
I just rolls it off I thought we could
just throw him onto the track and affect
the race then I was wrong was that a
legit crash or did we affect that with
the dead body where is the dead body oh
he's on the road he's it he's on the
road we can throw them on the roads
that's bloody fantastic somebody wrote
over him oh he's like oh oh the big boss
is back
you know what this is as soon as I see
your daughter this will become its part
out three two this is sparta
and hit the other body did you see it it
hit the body on the ground and then they
car think shot through the building and
crushed the entire game that was
fantastic
can we affect it we're just shooting the
car whilst it's driving she comes
you can shizzle I wasn't expecting that
Hoss bloody fantastic can it work in
another car no such target down
next up suppose I am great this is your
lucky day do well and there's a bonus in
you got it got it got it
everyone look alive and get to your
stations okay I'm install remote
explosive okay Sierra's coming in
everyone on your stations now
[Applause]
we'll just pop this here remote
explosive why don't watch it wrong I
suppose we could watch it from anywhere
we like it won't go off until we press
the button right remote explosive here
she comes
[Applause]
it sure does real time oh yeah jump on
my balls no you'd like yeah they do make
you a bit lightheaded hmm hey you're
sick okay I'll admit something I thought
I poisoned that I chose the wrong poison
so he should be dead already
again this guy throws it modern a
pregnant lady with morning sickness
anyway dude you know what I'm gonna say
there can be only one this have a nice
day so here are the two possible
outcomes of this meeting one you will
leave this place in this country for
good don't say - you say - it's going
wrong for you don't say too
spotter both targets down well done 47
thank you head for an exit and we'll
speak again soon okay darling hello
finally see you yes traffic was rough
let me show you everything is this the
way I'm gonna say something provocative
now Ted war is going out of fashion 30
it's just plain right don't TV no TV yes
I'm a grown man I just pick any other
pictures on the desk it's got a picture
it will kill you're saying well I do
like the cards you've got here on your
table sir they're very nice but I have a
picture of you from the table and scan
it just like I showed you it's perfect
okay I've got the picture of you
robotnik's make my day last words been a
lovely time I love this robots Oh fancy
meeting you two here see you next time
bit of pleasure run away right well yeah
we'll go we're in the wheel trims yes
now
[Applause]
you won't find someone who can put tires
on better than me look at that for a
piece of art yeah I think she's dead
target down next up because I'll take my
shovel in go it's gonna bend down again
ah ha ha we'll get you this time instead
man yeah run away in fact as soon as he
starts bending back of his neck yeah
popped a muscle there fella this black
stuff will burn you all alive let's make
a pile of people burns burns burns your
rings on fire yeah the ring
oh yeah it's getting too easy smoking
kills
ouch
she was really hot stuff turn the
careful there may a fart eat don't light
a match
okay should have happened by now
oh well again again right I'm staying
out here this time this is my finest
trap ever electrocution puddle version 2
I remember Paris last year while sorry
2016 actually the Paris mission I think
I got about 100 kills doing this
basically it's just a poodle and we keep
turning the electricity on and as they
get closer we get them all come on next
victim go and step a little bit further
forward sir I don't know what happened
there mate evil well we want more we
whoa whoa
exactly what do we know what is dude
what have you noticed later he was dead
and he stood back up to get electrocuted
again
my brain can't handle this my brain
cannot handle this last word I think we
should move on now we've been doing this
for about two hours
[Laughter]
okay we'll sabotage sabotage everyone
loves a bit of sabotage sabotage some of
launch some of launch where's the boss's
good looking strike are you darling sexy
man we are sexy man he is you want me to
get in them Kronstadt racers are kicking
ass cross the up thanks mate right yeah
I'm in boss what do you want to do
it's man to worry okay here we go now
that is how to backfire we're at the
exit where's the helicopter where is the
helicopter there's a nest this is weird
this is very strange exhibition from a
nest no he's not gonna fly he's flying
with a shotgun through his torso he is
agent 47 that is so random I do love the
Easter eggs in this game anyway let's
call it there we've completed about half
the missions available in this area
there's at least another 30 to go
through plus another five sandbox worlds
to discover - I'll be back next week to
find more brutal and ridiculous ways to
complete agent 47s next mission it's
been a pleasure
as always I'll see you next time